an adventurous life holds the key to
unlocking positive emotions in one 2020
experiment from New York University and
the University of Miami scientists
attempted to quantify the effects of
approaching the world with a sense of
adventure they enlisted over 130
participants and got their consent to
track their location using the GPS in
their phones over the next several
months the researchers sent the
participants text messages asking them
about their emotions how happy excited
or relaxed did they feel the results
were eye opening as the GPS data and
responses to the text messages rolled in
it became clear that those who had more
adventurous experiences those who took
themselves off to a wider and more
random assortment of places whether
taking a new route to work or trying a
different coffee shop rather than
sticking to their regular one felt
happier more excited and more relaxed
their conclusion